- Welcome everyone, I
am Priyamvada Natarajan.
I'm an astrophysicist
and the current director
of the Franke Program in Science
and the Humanities at Yale,
which is our flagship
interdisciplinary program.
So I'm delighted to see you
all in the audience today
gathered for a wonderful
event this evening.
We have a treat in store, a book talk
by one of our very own
distinguished faculty members,
Carlos Eire.
Okay, on to this evening's event,
Carlos Eire is the Lawrason Riggs
Professor of History and Religious Studies
and he received his PhD from Yale in 1979
and he specializes in the
social, intellectual, religious
and cultural history of the late medieval
and early modern Europe with a focus on
both the Protestant and
Catholic reformations.
The history of the
supernatural, which is of course
what really fascinated both
Dr. Kamp who as you all know,
without whom this event
would not have happened.
We are both fan girls of his work
on the history of the supernatural
and the history of death.
Before joining the Yale faculty in 1996,
he taught at St. John's
University in Minnesota,
the University of Virginia,
and was a member of the Institute
for Advanced Study at
Princeton for two years.
He's the author of multiple books,
including "The War Against the Idols,"
"The Reformation of Worship,
From Erasmus to Calvin,"
"From Madrid to Purgatory,
the Art and Craft of Dying
in 16th century Spain."
"A very Brief History of
Eternity," which I love that title,
I have not read that
book should get that one.
"Reformations, the Early Modern World,"
"The Life of St. Theresa
of Avila" biography.
"And they Flew: A History
of the Impossible,"
which is what we are going
to be hearing about today,
the subject of today's talk.
He's also the co-author of
"Jews, Christians, Muslims:
an Introduction to Monotheistic Religions"
and has also ventured into
later time span in history
to the 20th century
and the Cuban Revolution in the memoir,
"Waiting for Snow in Havana,"
which was published in 2003
and it won the National
Book Award for nonfiction
in the United States
and has been translated into
more than a dozen languages.
His second memoir,
"Learning to Die in Miami,"
explores the exile experience
of being in this country.
A past president of the Society
for Reformation Research,
he's currently working on several topics
in the history of the supernatural.
His book, "Reformations"
also won many prizes,
including the RR Hawkins Prize
for the best book of the year
from the American Publishers Association.
And the award for the best
book in the humanities in 2017.
Was also awarded the
Yaroslav Pelikan Prize
by Yale University Press.
So interestingly, all of his
books are banned in Cuba,
and you know what that means?
You are immediately a celebrity
once you have a banned book.
It's almost better than having a stalker,
which is supposed to be
like the first mark of,
having arrived at celebritydom
where he has been proclaimed
an enemy of the state.
That actually sounds scarier
than just having your books banned.
A distinction that he regards
as the highest of all his honors.
So hopefully in the Q&A,
we can ask him a little
bit more about that.
So I just want to give you a brief
notice of upcoming exciting events.
We are hosting a conference
on the nature of inference
for those of you who've been attending
the Understanding the
Nature of Inference series,
our conference is on the
14th and 15th of December
at the Greenberg
Conference Center at Yale.
And if you would like to attend,
please go to the website and register.
And in spring 2024, we have
a ton of exciting events.
Preview of coming attractions,
we have Dr. Meredith Broussard
who's investigating the
ways in which big data
and technology are reinforcing
race and gender inequality in our society
will be giving us a talk.
We have a screening of Richland,
a new documentary on a small town
struggling with its identity
as a center of weapon
grade plutonium production.
And then we have Christian
Cooper on April 4th,
he was the victim
of the Central Park Bird watching incident
for those of you who may remember.
So we have a lot of events
coming up in the spring
and now I want to, without further ado,
invite Carlos to come and speak to us,
thank you so much for
accepting our invitation.
(applause)
- Well, thank you and thanks to everyone
responsible for making this happen.
And thank you all for
being here on a cold,
it's almost December afternoon.
Is a history of the impossible possible?
History of the impossible
is the subtitle of my book for a reason.
And this lecture will focus
on this issue of how any
objective historian can
write a history of things
that almost everyone, if not everyone
thinks cannot happen and
have not ever happened.
So moving on, how can one write
a history of the impossible?
I chose two impossible miracles
that most people would agree
are not only impossible,
but as an audience member
has already suggested to me,
you're not doing the
history of the impossible,
you're doing the history
of the ridiculous.
Or as the review that appeared
in The Spectator UK website last week
accused me of sliding into silliness,
I chose two impossible miracles,
levitation and bilocation.
Oh, scary stuff.
For all scholars, historians
or non historians alike,
there can be a war between the facts.
First fact before I get
into Troeltsch and James,
there is no denying the fact
that we have testimonies of levitating
and bilocating human beings,
that is a fact and it's a
fact that can't be denied,
we have testimonies.
But what kind of fact can one deal with
when one deals with the impossible?
Well, Ernst Troeltsch, social scientist
came up with a very useful concept
many, many, many years ago.
The social fact, what is a social fact?
Let me explain before I
get to the fine points.
Social fact is an idea or concept
or a set of beliefs that are widely held
and perhaps so widely held
and perhaps even defended
or demanded, demands
certain kinds of behavior
that one cannot simply go against them.
We all live with social facts
and for instance, in our own day and age,
it is a social fact that some
words have become threatened,
there are certain words
you cannot say in public
unless you like being pilloried.
That's a social fact, and we live with it.
Levitation and bilocation,
also social facts
throughout history and in
some parts of the world.
And as I used to, when I
used to consult with my
colleagues who do Asian religions
and I told them what my project was,
they were not the least bit impressed
levitation, bilocation, so what?
Yeah, of course, of course
it's a social fact in much
of older Asian religion,
social fact.
But there are anomalous events,
let's call them miracles,
which cannot ever be ascribed
to supernatural causes,
that's our social fact that we live with.
These anomalous events cannot
or should not be ascribed
to supernatural causes.
And it is a social fact
accepted, very widely accepted
that humans cannot defy
gravity without technology.
And also that humans cannot be present
in two places simultaneously.
These are social facts widely accepted
in our own day and age.
But then there are also wild facts.
One of my favorite terms
from William James,
brother of Henry James,
what is a wild fact?
It's an anomalous event
that just doesn't fit any pigeonhole,
it's actually like the
proverbial square peg
that cannot go into the round hole.
Some anomalous events,
let's call them wild
facts, defy explanation.
And these are our wild facts
when it comes to the two
miracles I've examined.
We have thousands of reports
of humans hovering and flying
and we have thousands of reports of humans
being in two places simultaneously.
But before I go any
further, the accepted way
of approaching any of these
wild facts for a historian
is to place brackets around
the phenomenon itself.
The event can be studied, the
testimonies can be studied,
but the proper thing to do is
to take either a functionalist
or structuralist approach to the event
and analyze what meaning and purpose
belief in this event
has for the people who are testifying
that they witnessed it.
So you have to bring your
brackets to the phenomenon.
I am trying to question the
brackets or their necessity,
but down to brass tacks,
what is a miracle?
In the Christian tradition,
which is the only tradition
I'm focusing on in my book,
Saint Augustine of Hippo, was challenged
by a Manechean named
Faustus who argued that
Christian miracles were contrary to nature
and therefore false, impossible.
Augustine replied by saying that there is,
and I quote, "There is
no impropriety in saying
that God does something against
nature when it is contrary
to what we know of nature.
For we give the name nature
to the usual and known course of nature
and whatever God does contrary to this
we call prodigies or miracles."
So the focus is on whatever
knowledge one has of nature,
not what the laws of nature are accepted
in one's day and time might be.
Aquinas in the 13th century
had this definition of miracle
in Summa Contra Gentiles,
a miracle is a sensible
effect produced by God,
which transcends all the forces of nature,
with emphasis on transcends.
And a miracle, Aquinas argued
does not contradict, destroy, antagonize,
or violate the forces of nature.
It is an effect which exceeds
all the inherent powers
of the forces of nature,
it is something that
happens as an exception
to the regular working
of the established order.
And God, who made the forces of nature
can cause something to happen at his will,
which gives evidence of his
dominion over these forces.
But along comes the
Protestant reformation in 1517
can be dated exactly
till October 31st, 1517.
Here's Martin Luther on miracles.
"Those visible works are
simply signs for the ignorant,
unbelieving crowd and for their sakes
that are yet to be attracted."
But as for us who know
already all we do know
and believe the gospel,
what do we want them for?"
Main point, Luther and all the other major
first and second generation
Protestant reformers
rejected the existence of any miracles
post the year 100.
I'll get to that in a
couple of minutes, why this,
they thought this was so.
Second generation reformer,
John Calvin on miracles
and this is key.
"We may also fitly remember
that Satan has his miracles,
which though they are deceitful tricks
rather than true powers, are
such a sort as to mislead
the simple-minded and untutored."
Look at that condescension.
"Idolatry has been nourished
by wonderful miracles,
yet these are not sufficient
to sanction the superstition
either of magicians
or idolaters," harsh words Calvin.
Of course, Protestant
reformation was all about
returning to the Bible, the Bible alone.
So what about all those
miracles in the Bible?
In the Hebrew Bible,
the Old Testament is full of miracles,
like God crossing the Red Sea
and many, many, many others.
And the New Testament
is full of miracles too.
Is a Christ healing the blind man
Renaissance period painting.
But it's not just the gospels
that are full of miracles,
the acts of the apostles also relates that
the apostles themselves,
after Jesus's resurrection and ascension
performed all sorts of miracles,
and not just healing miracles
but wondrous miracles
such as St. Paul being
bitten by a venomous snake
and surviving totally unharmed.
What to do, what to do?
There are miracles in the Bible,
why can't there be any miracles now?
But before I go any further with slides,
there is this very significant tactical,
polemical issue that all the
first and second generation
Protestant reformers had to face.
Their Catholic opponents
were constantly asking,
where are your miracles, right?
We have a long history of miracles
and we have all these miracles,
where are your miracles?
Your church must be false.
So solution,
miracles stopped at the year 100.
It's known in Protestant theology
as the cessation of miracles argument.
That this doctrine affirms
that the miracles described
in the Bible ceased
at the end of the apostolic
age, around the year 100.
And why 100?
Well that was the
accepted date more or less
for the death of the
last of the 12 apostles,
the apostle John.
Jesus had commissioned the apostles
'cause in the gospels
there is blatantly stated
that he gives them power to do
all these miraculous things.
But there's nothing else in
the New Testament that says
that this was, had a
expiration code stamped on it.
The argument ran like this
for the cessation of miracles.
Miracles were necessary to convince people
that Jesus was indeed the son of God.
Once the first and second
and perhaps even third generation
of converts were won over
to belief in Jesus as the
Messiah and the Son of God,
miracles were no longer necessary
because the greatest miracle
of all about Christianity
was the fact that more
people kept converting
without miracles.
That was the greatest miracle of all.
And here's a book from 1917
by Benjamin Warfield,
"Counterfeit Miracles,"
which was all about the
cessation of miracles argument
because in later Protestantism,
the cessation of miracles
doctrine came under attack.
Now Warfield here is
defending still in 1917,
the cessation of miracles argument.
And there's a long text from John Calvin.
I won't read all of it, but
this is a important passage.
"The gift of healing was temporary,
all are constrained to affirm
and events clearly prove."
Then he goes on to say anyone,
the rest of the statement basically says
that anyone who is claiming a miracle
past the apostolic age is
aping, that's the verb,
aping the apostles and
simply fooling people.
Then came the enlightenment
following upon the Protestant Reformation.
And for some reason try this,
Google the name of any
enlightenment philosopher
in sunglasses and you're likely
to get an image like this.
Voltaire, "It is impossible
that a being infinitely wise
can have made laws to violate them.
He could not derange the machine
but with a view of making it work better.
But it is evident that God
all wise and omnipotent
originally made this immense machine,
the universe as good and
perfect as he was able.
If he saw that some imperfections
would arise from the nature of matter,
he provided for that in the beginning,
and accordingly, he will
never change anything in it."
How rational, very rational.
And also an echo of
Faustus, the mannequin.
Everyone's favorite, David
Hume, dialogue on miracles.
Miracle is a violation
of the laws of nature,
Faustus the manechean again.
"The plain consequence is,
and it is a general maxim
worthy of our attention
that no testimony is sufficient
to establish a miracle."
I'll pause there, we have
all these testimonies, right?
That's the fact we have,
we have testimonies.
But he says no testimony
is sufficient to establish a miracle
unless the testimony be of
such a kind that its falsehood
would be more miraculous than the fact
which it endeavors to
establish, classic Hume.
A miracle supported by any human testimony
is more properly a subject
of derision than an argument.
Hence, how does one do
in a post Humean world,
a history of the impossible?
The Catholic church tried to align itself
against the cessation
of miracles doctrine,
and against all Protestant arguments
against Catholic miracles.
Remember that line from Calvin,
Satan too has his miracles?
Part of the Protestant
argument was that any
post apostolic age miracle
claimed by the Catholic church
could only be a demonic
trick rather than a miracle.
Yes, Satan has his miracles,
we'll return to this curious
asymmetry, I call it,
between Catholic and Protestant
thinking on the miraculous.
But this man Prospero
Lambertini, an enlightened pope
who became Pope Benedict the 14th,
and look at his dates, 1740 to 1758.
He served, by the way,
as the devil's advocate
in Rome for several years,
that's the person charged
in canonization cases with
calling into doubt
everything that's being
presented about the same.
So he knew exactly what was going on.
There's a wonderful book titled,
"The Rationalization of
Miracle," by Paolo Parigi,
if you're interested in this subject,
he details how it was
that in the 17th century
the Catholic Church adopted
a more "scientific approach"
to all these testimonies about
saints and their miracles.
And actually it was Pope Benedict XIV,
who more than anyone else,
stressed that in the canonization process,
what mattered most
was heroic virtue rather
than miracle working.
And it still to this day
remains the primary objective
in Catholic canonization process.
Even though you still need miracles,
they're a secondary nature.
And he wrote this massive,
it's a multi-volume book, (speaks Italian)
on the Beatification
of the Servants of God
and the Canonization of the Blessing,
which when I first saw the title, I said,
oh, I must run and read
this book until I realized
how humongous it was.
And that, by the way, this
is still pretty much in use.
Some tweaking has been done,
but this is still the
guidebook to this day.
But okay, Protestant
reformation enlightenment,
then comes the secular age
and along comes the
invention of social science,
and this man in particular
is a very scary looking man, Max Weber.
Argued that the key turning
point in western history
had been this Protestant
cessation of miracles doctrine,
that is what made the world modern.
The key point was in English translation,
the disenchantment of the world,
in German is much clearer
the deep magic demagification of the world
because the German word Zauber is magic.
So along with the Protestant reformers
who assigned all miracles to Satan,
now Weber is pairing up,
and Protestant reformers did this too.
Paired Catholic rituals
and miracles with magic,
which Christians have never
thought as something good.
So what kind of, Entzauberang is there
from the Protestant reformers?
Well, there are no more
sacramental miracles
like the Eucharist, the bread and wine
turning into the actual physical
flesh and blood of Christ.
Although Luther continued to
believe in the real presence,
he did not believe that
it could be explained.
And it definitely was
not the body and blood
under some other guise.
Other Protestant reformers went further
denying the real presence.
All the miracles in the
lives of the saints,
such as this one depicted here
by Diego Velazquez's
"Temptation of St. Thomas"
where angels came to rescue
him from a prostitute
his family had placed in his room
so that he would change his mind
and not join the Dominican order.
And if COVID does return,
you can get this very nice
mask, which also, if
you believe in miracles,
will repel the COVID virus.
And miracles within mystical
visions, forget about them.
Human beings do not cross the
boundary into the supernatural
and cannot, that was
part of the Entzauberung,
or disenchantment of the world.
And human beings don't have visions
of people in heaven like
the Virgin Mary or Jesus.
No, simply does not happen.
Mystical ecstasy?
No.
And the physical phenomena
or physical miracles that
accompany mystical ecstasy
such as the stigmata, no.
If something like this happens,
for Protestant theologians, it's demonic,
for enlightened humans, it's a trick,
it's probably self-inflicted.
So here's the tough one, levitation.
And one reason I picked levitation
is not only that it's so
scandalously impossible,
but also that the
individuals that I focus on
in the 16th and 17th century,
the testimonies of their
levitation are such that
if one accepts the
testimonies at face value,
the levitation could not have been a trick
perform with wires or ropes
or any other such contraptions.
But I'll pause before I forge ahead.
Levitation was faked all the time,
and especially in the
16th and 17th century.
And we have lots of records
of how these fraudsters
are then processed, caught,
and in many ways, punished.
And there's a whole section of my book
that focuses on the frauds
as pretty much a control
in a scientific experiment.
All right, you've got someone
whose levitation are accepted
by the Catholic church.
For every person whose
levitations are accepted,
you've got several whose levitations
have been rejected as fraudulent.
So there is this back to
the Prospero Lambertini
and the method of
rationalizing the miraculous
and approaching miracles empirically.
Levitation is not found
in the New Testament,
except for perhaps this cryptic passage
from St. Paul in Corinthians,
2nd Corinthians quote,
"I know a man in Christ who 14 years ago,
was caught up to the third
heaven, whether in the body
or out of the body, I
don't know, God knows."
It's the only kind of passage
that comes close to hinting at levitation.
But there are some magicians,
non-Christian magicians,
first, second, third,
fourth, fifth, sixth century
who are going around
levitating such as Simon Magus.
But Christian saints levitating,
you don't find them in the early church.
You begin to see them in
the later middle ages.
And the first depiction
of a levitating saint
that anyone knows has been painted
is this one by Giotto
of the Ecstasy of St. Francis, 1295.
And in the life of Francis by Bonaventure,
here's the text that goes with this image.
"There he was beheld praying by night,
his hands stretched out
after the manner of a cross,
his whole body uplifted from the earth
and wrapped in a shining cloud
as though the wondrous
illumination of the body
were a witness unto the wondrous
enlightenment of his mind."
So he's not only levitating, he's glowing.
Let's skip ahead.
There are numerous levitating saints
in the later Middle ages.
As a matter of fact, with
each passing century,
the numbers of levitating
saints gets higher and higher.
And we get to the 16th century.
It's a response to the
Protestant reformation.
Okay, you guys don't
have miracles, but we do.
And the number of
levitating saints increases
in the 16th century and 17th century.
But part of this increase,
it has a lot to do
with the invention of the printing press
and the publication of hagiographies
or lives of the saints,
this is one reason it's much easier
to find levitating saints
in the early modern period
than even the later centuries
of the Middle Ages, is that
you've got hagiographies
that are printed and distributed widely.
And here we have the
founder of the Jesuit order,
St. Ignatius Loyola, who was observed
levitating and glowing.
He was observed many times at night,
his room filled with a bright light,
he's seen raised up in the
air with his knees bent,
weeping, sighing, and saying,
"My God, how infinitely good you are."
And the Jesuit hagiographers
liked this scene very much.
These three images are
from graphic hagiographies,
a genre of hagiography
that became very popular
from the mid 16th century
into the 17th century.
Where you know, you pick
up the life of the saint
and it's basically like a comic book.
And the text is, and I left
the text here so you could see
how little text there is
accompanying the image.
So image after image after image.
And notice also in these depictions,
there is always a witness,
the testimony is linked to the image.
St Teresa of Avila also
levitating and glowing.
And this happened in front
of the Bishop of Avila
and a crowd of witnesses.
I'll pause for a second and add something
about St. Teresa that's not in the slides.
St. Teresa hated to levitate
and tried to resist it
and begged her nuns,
actually ordered them because
she was their superior.
If you see me going up, hold me down.
If I do go up, pull me down.
And she would hold on to
any object that she could
as she felt it coming on
and tried to stay
grounded, unsuccessfully.
Including one time in the
kitchen while she was frying eggs
with the last few drops,
precious drops of olive oil
that her convent had left.
And she goes up with a
frying pan in her hand.
But the nuns are under obedience,
so they're trying to pull her down,
but they're worried that
precious oil is going to spill,
but they cannot pull her down.
I'll add this too,
this is very common of early modern
as well as medieval levitations.
When does it happen?
It happens during mystical ecstasy.
It is a byproduct of mystical ecstasy.
And it is not something that is willed,
it's against your will.
But more than that, you see it here.
You see it in these two and other images.
In mystical ecstasy, certain
kinds of mystical ecstasy,
the body goes into a cataleptic seizure
and that's a medical term, becomes rigid.
The senses cease to work
whatever position you're in
when you enter mystical
ecstasy, you're frozen.
And it's kind of humorous,
but also very sad.
Many of these levitating
saints, their communities,
prick them with needles,
place candle lit candles
right in front of their eyes.
Or my favorite, blow on them
because they're so nearly weightless,
blow on them to watch their
body waft across the room
while they are in this cataleptic state.
So Teresa resisted, and
we don't have time for it,
but she is the, not the only one,
but the one levitator
who has devoted the most page space
in her writings to describing
what it feels like to levitate
and what it feels like
to resist these levitations.
And there she is levitating
jointly with St. John of the cross
one Trinity Sunday in either 1573 or '74,
nobody has fixed the date,
but they were discussing the trinity
and all of a sudden
whoop, they both go up.
And here's another depiction of this.
I began this project 40
years ago in June of 1983
when visiting the convent
of the incarnation in Avila.
Tour guide is taking us around.
Here's the kitchen where Teresa cooked
with her pots and pans.
Here's the refectory where the nuns ate.
And one of my favorites,
here's the staircase
where the devil pushed
Teresa down the stairs
and she broke her arm.
And then we got to this
spot, the locutorio,
where the nuns spoke
with the outside world.
And here's the spot where
Teresa and John of the cross
levitated together for
the very first time,
my head exploded.
It was a cognitive
experience like I have never had before.
There's nothing emotional about it,
it's purely rational, Kant
would've been very proud of me.
Here's it's a fact to
the people in this place,
this is a fact.
And from here on in, on and
off, on and off, over 40 years
until COVID hit.
And then this book was
written mostly during COVID
and by then a miracle,
the older, a text was, a printed text,
the older it was, more likely
it was, I would find it online
and every hagiography I needed,
every single one except two
or three was online for me.
So I didn't need to leave the house.
And from the bowels of
Yale library system,
if I requested a book,
it would be neatly wrapped in brown paper
and mailed to my
doorstep, another miracle.
So greatest levitator of all time.
St. Joseph of Cupertino, 1663,
I mean 1603 to 1663.
And you have here three
different depictions
of the same levitation.
He looks more like Superman
than any other character
you might be familiar with.
What's so special about St. Joseph?
And look at the time period,
1603-1663 Protestant Reformation
is already triumphed,
taken over great chunks of Europe.
So this is a century
after Luther and Calvin.
But from very early
age, he was very pious,
he would go into mystical
ecstasies and levitate.
But he also happened to
be mentally challenged.
And his name, his nickname
given to him by locals
was Boccaperta, Open mouth.
So the village idiot basically
who was rejected twice by,
first by the Franciscans
and secondly the Capuchins
because he couldn't do
anything right except levitate,
which hindered his work.
Long story short, he ends up becoming
member of the Franciscan order
and being ordained a priest,
his ordination was meant to be
a humiliation to his superior
who was treating him like,
pardon the expression, a moron.
Oh, so you're treating this man this way,
I'll teach you some humility.
You prepare him to be a priest
and you make sure he gets ordained.
He managed to pass the test
'cause the only question
asked of him was on the only
passage out of the entire
Bible that he knew by memory,
which is why he is the
patron saint of test takers.
Processed by the inquisition, he passes.
Why would the inquisition processes?
Well this could be demonic you know,
same thing with St. Teresa,
same thing with all these
other early modern levitators,
they had to clear away the suspicion
that this might be the devil at work.
And what was the best way
to clear away the suspicion?
Humility, humility, these
people are not trying
to attract attention to themselves,
they're always humble in
their dealings with others.
Joseph not only levitated, he flew
and he flew forwards and
backwards, sometimes upside down.
And here's an image of him
upon seeing the shrine of
the holy house of Loreto,
he goes up.
And many descriptions of him
are going up as high as trees treetops,
one time he goes up to
a treetop levitating
and then comes out of his
ecstasy in the treetop
and they have to get a very
tall ladder to help him down.
And this painter is unknown,
this just sold at auction last year.
No price disclosed, no owner disclosed,
I'd like to know who has
this hanging in their palace.
Joseph had triggers, what
triggered his ecstasies?
All sorts of things, religious
imagery especially hence,
his flying to that cross.
Sacred places,
seeing the shrine of the
Holy House of Loreto.
And the image to the left
is actually St. Joseph
flying over the heads
of the Spanish Viceroy
in Italy and his wife
and their entire entourage
and his wife fainted
and had to be revived with smelling salts,
you see her there passed
out right under Joseph.
But the reason he flew over
their heads is he had seen
this image of the Virgin Mary
and was just immediately, ah, mama,
that's what he called these images, mama.
Other triggers, the
sacraments saying Mass.
Most of his levitations
occurred while saying Mass.
And I'll return to this
in a minute or two.
And people in need of
healing or of conversion.
These two paintings
blend all these triggers.
On the left, you have him
dragging up a young man
who had lost his mind and
was considered insane.
He placed his hand on him to
heal him and went up with him.
And it's a double miracle,
a levitation and a healing.
The other image is St. Joseph of Cupertino
saying mass levitating at mass,
and the person astounded
is Johan Friedrich,
the Lutheran Duke of Saxony
who converted to Catholicism
after seeing Joseph
levitate in this manner.
And again, I have some
pauses, this is another pause.
A scientist in the UK, in Wales
got an advanced copy of
my book and emailed me,
he was very excited
by my descriptions of
St. Joseph's levitations.
And the email said
basically, I'm paraphrasing,
I am so happy this proves
so much about my theory
of levitations being
a break in time space.
And what he likes so much
about Joseph is the fact that,
this cataleptic posture
involved not only his body
but his clothing, which
retained its folds,
the folds would not change.
And even when upside down,
the habit would not come
flopping down over his head,
it would stay.
And when coming out of
the cataleptic seizure,
especially when saying mass,
Joseph, even after three
hours, would pick up
whatever spot in the missile
he was at, the next word.
So this scientist got
all excited because yes,
he's outside of time
space, there's no time.
Oh, he was so excited.
I couldn't be as excited
'cause I couldn't understand
the technical terminology
he was throwing at me.
He went into ecstasy in
solitude as well as in public.
And even went over the
head of Pope Urban VIII,
who supposedly exclaimed, "If
this man dies before I do,
I will testify at his canonization inquest
that he flew over my head."
So talk about testimonies.
This is one of the highest placed people
who testified that he
did in fact defy gravity.
So in the baroque period,
17th century mostly,
you begin to see in Catholic sacred art,
more and more depictions
of levitating saints
and especially of
medieval levitating saints
who had not received attention
from medieval artists.
So here you have a
very, very odd rendition
of the stigmatization of St.
Francis by Vicente Carducho,
an Italian artist who
hispanicized his name
from Carduchi to Carducho, who
his father is also an artist
who was brought to the Spanish court.
And on the right you also
have another Carducho,
levitation of St. Anthony of Padua,
a contemporary of St. Francis.
And a levitation of St.
Dominic, 13th century
and a another Carducho vision of St. Hugo,
one of the early carthusian monks.
Carducho was a specialist from what,
as far as I can tell,
I'm not an art historian.
And every colleague I've ever had
in any art history
department always reminds me,
you are not an art historian.
But Carducho has more
paintings representing
levitating saints than
anyone else I found.
So the past, the history,
the miracle is therefore
thrown to the past for display,
either on monastery or
convent walls or church walls.
And here's one of the
most amazing depictions,
baroque depictions of levitation
from Murillo and other Spanish artists.
There are arguments still going on
as to who this Franciscan friar is,
doesn't matter, he was in the kitchen,
he, under his bow of obedience,
he was supposed to do kitchen
work, but he went into ecstasy
and started levitating and glowing.
So angels came to do his work.
And there on the left,
you see the eyewitnesses
who come and find him.
This painting is huge and it
hangs in the Louvre Museum.
It was stolen by Napoleon's
army and never returned.
So add this to the list
with the Elgin marbles,
things that need to be returned.
The other miracle is bilocation.
And here's your familiar
figure, ah, here's where we are,
and there it is.
You can buy that inflatable
scream figure, by the way,
just Google it.
Don't tell my wife,
she's getting that for
a Christmas present.
Giotto, also bilocation by St. Francis.
So again, throwing
things back to the past.
Greatest bilocator, not the greatest
'cause I found one later,
but an extreme bilocator.
So Maria De Agreda, almost
the same exact dates
as St. Joseph, 1602 to 1665,
a Franciscan nun who bilocated repeatedly
and crossed the ocean,
never left Agreda physically,
but was seen by the Jumano natives
in present day New Mexico and Texas,
visited them reportedly over
500 times to Christianize them.
This is a tricky case, very tricky.
But she acquired such a reputation
as being a genuine bilocator
that she is a legend
in the American southwest.
And by sheer coincidence, one of my
teaching fellows last year
was traveling through San Angelo, Texas.
Sent me a photo, San Angelo,
Texas has erected a huge statue
of the lady in blue as
she was known in that area
'cause her habit had a little bit of blue.
So she crossed the ocean back and forth.
And as if that were not enough,
another impossible miracle,
I decided to not focus
on too much in the book.
The Virgin Mary appeared to her constantly
and dictated her
autobiography to this nun.
And she wrote it down,
was ordered to burn it, she burned it.
Another superior came in and says,
where's that life of Mary?
Oh, I was asked to burn it,
oh, write it over again.
It's over a million words long.
"The Mystical City of
God" is the English title.
And it guess which film
relied on it heavily?
Mel Gibson's the passion of the Christ.
She describes things that
are not in the New Testament.
So it's an even iffier
sort of impossible miracle
because her mystical city of God
could be considered a fifth Gospel.
And there in this painting,
you see her paired up
with none other than John the evangelist,
who was also for a long time
believed to be the author
of the Book of Revelation
or the Apocalypse with the new
Jerusalem in the background.
And there you see the sheer
size of this work of hers,
which ended up being condemned
by the faculty theological
faculty of the Sorbone,
but approved by no surprise,
Salamanca, Alcala, Luvent,
which was under Spanish control,
but inexplicable, Toulouse,
they all approved it.
Here's a fact nobody disputes
the first man to ever levitate
with help in a hot air balloon,
Jean-Francois Pilatre de
Rozier, love that name, 1783.
But then, to wrap up, there is
the wrong kind of levitation,
witches were believed to levitate and fly.
And just read the Malleus
Maleficarum from the 15th century,
the witchcraft treatise of
all of witchcraft treatises
tells you how they fly to
their sabbaths, how they,
rub oil on themselves and fly.
Protestants continued to believe
just about a hundred percent
of Catholic medieval Catholic demonology.
But they rejected much of the theology
and all of the miracles,
that's the asymmetry I
was referring to before.
So the peak period for flying saints
is also the peak period for
flying witches and witch hunts,
which is why I say the
16th and 17th century
is the peak period for flying humans
before the invention of hot
air balloons and airplanes.
Levitation was possible for Protestants,
the image on the left or flying witches
and the devil from an English text.
On the right, you see how long this idea
or belief might have persisted in Spain,
here's a painting by Francisco
Goya, right on the edge
between the 18th and 19th century.
A series of paintings on witchcraft
commissioned by some patron
I don't know much about.
And to show how perverse
historians can be,
or at least how perverse I am.
One of the happiest days
in my research of this book
is when I found a Protestant
demonic possession that
involved levitation
in Boston in 1693.
A description of a young teenage girl
who could not be held down
or pulled down from the
ceiling by several burly men.
And that's how they're described, burly,
who had been brought there
by none other than the great
Puritan minister Cotton Mather,
who made them all sign
affidavits testifying
they had been unable to restrain
the girl or pull her down.
So there's symmetry, but there's asymmetry
as far as the causality
of these levitations.
But of course, levitation can be a trick.
It's done frequently,
and there, you can learn how to levitate.
But my cases, if the
descriptions are in fact
truthful testimony, there's
no way those levitations
could have been faked.
And it comes back in 19th and
20th century spiritualism.
Upper left, a levitation
by the great 19th century spiritualist,
Daniel Dunglas Home, which took place
in South Manchester,
Connecticut in the 1830s.
And on the right you see a
Welsh spiritualist levitating.
The reason everyone looks so asleep
is that the photo is
taken in infrared light
and the man holding the
switch for the camera
is none other than the levitator.
So levitation is absolutely possible.
We have gadgets you can put
on your desk that levitate,
we have electromagnetic trains.
One of my sons spent two years in Japan.
He levitated for two years
every time he took the
electromagnetic train.
And bilocation, we do it all the time.
But of course, the
bilocations and levitations
that I've studied are of a
very, very different sort.
And yes, I will be constantly
reminded how ridiculous
and how silly the subject is.
But to me, it's not silly at all.
And I'm not saying
I can prove that any
of these things happen,
what I'm saying is that
historians need to adjust a little bit
to supernatural events.
Let's call them paranormal,
let's call them wild facts.
Those brackets that I was taught to wield
in this very building many years ago,
don't you ever consider the
supernatural real, you can't.
Those brackets need shrinking, let's say,
and as I argue in my
book, if you want to be
truly skeptical as any
good scientist should be,
I could boast of being
Cartesian, following Descartes,
De Omnibus et Dubitandum,
everything ought to be doubted,
including dogmatic materialism.
And I'm eager to hear your
questions and comments.
(applause)
- Thank you so much.
- You want both?
- Yeah, I think that'll maybe ask.
- Okay.
- Yeah, switched on.
- Okay, questions, thank you
so much, that was fascinating.
- Just as a comment, I think a lot of
controversy that you
faced could be prevented
by changing the subtitle of your book.
It could be, "What do we call Impossible?"
because this is the crux of the matter.
It's like, I bought my
son a book at some point
by Nobel laureate and the title was
"Impossible Takes Longer."
And any field, I'm an experimental
biologist, in any field
there small miracles where
half of the field says no,
or all of them say no, it's impossible.
They fire a person, he goes in hiding
and then 25 years later or 50 years later,
he gets a Nobel Prize
because what was impossible is possible.
The same thing if you gave
this lecture 200 years ago
saying that you can talk to,
I can talk to my son in France,
it would be, so the key is
I think you an somebody,
St. Augustine or Aquinas,
you quoted it's impossible
is you call impossible
what is unexplainable
to us at this stage of-
- That's right.
- What we know.
- Because everything else
then becomes like literature.
- Yeah, no, I agree with
you a hundred percent,
but I have my tongue firmly
planted in my cheek by,
I'm trying to rile up people
by calling it a history of the impossible.
Precisely because of
what you just say that,
there are many things that one
were once thought impossible that aren't,
and actually I thought I
was doing something novel,
but I have found several other books with
the impossible in the title
used in a similar way,
including this book by
historian of religion at Rice
University, Jeffrey Krippal,
K-R-I-P-P-A-L, authors of the Impossible,
which is about 19th and
20th century writers
from all kinds of specialties
who write about impossible things.
But yeah, I agree with you, it's.
- Carlos.
- Yeah, hi.
- I'm Roberto Gonzalez Echevarría
professor of literature
here at Yale now retired,
but I'm here also as a member
of the Yale Aviation Club
(laughter)
because I'm a pilot, as is Taia here,
who's also a member of
the Yale Aviation Club.
We laugh because isn't
there something humorous
in this business of flying nuns?
- Yes, yeah, well, certainly there is.
And you know, most of the flying nuns
end up being processed by the inquisition
and discovered to be frauds.
So the issue is, why are some
deemed legitimate and some not legitimate?
Why are there tricks discovered
and why are other people's
tricks not discovered?
We actually had a very
interesting discussion in my,
one of my classes yesterday.
It's of course history
of the supernatural.
And we were dealing with
19th century spiritualists,
seances and so on.
- [Priyamvada] Mesmerism, right?
- And mesmerism and theosophy.
But anyway, the image you
saw of Daniel Dunglas Home,
he is the one spiritualist
medium that no scientist
could crack, discover or prove
that he had some trickery
involved in his things.
So that's what keeps me flying.
But St. Joseph is your patron saint
or anyone who flies, it's the
patron saint of all flyers,
ironically, a job given to him by
American bomber pilots
who were bombing the hell out of Italy
during the Second World War, who proposed,
hey, here's a good patron
saint for all flyers.
- If I may follow up on
the earlier question,
it is true that all
knowledge is provisional
and that what we know even
in science is best to date
and is apt to get
refined, changed, altered.
But do you think that
when these visualizations
and these claims were made,
people were not really
looking for an explanation?
Although I noticed that you noted that
any time you had someone levitating,
there was a witness,
there was another person
in the frame who could
testify that this.
So there's sort of this nod to evidence,
but at the same time, when
you look at those images,
at least at the time, they were
not meant to be challenged.
- That's right, no,
they're not meant to be.
- No, cause was sought.
- No, and as a matter of fact,
the Protestants too are
looking for causality,
there's always a search for causality.
But why does Cotton Mather
insist that these burly men
sign an affidavit?
Say, yes, I was there and
I tried to hold her down.
It's because they know
there are challenges.
And I think that many of those paintings
actually were commissioned
because those commissioning them knew
that this was not believed
by a hundred percent of
the people anywhere, that
there was skepticism.
And I found not in regards to levitation,
but another miracle
attributed to St. Teresa,
her corpse refused to decompose.
And in one of her hagiographies,
the hagiographer says,
you don't wanna believe,
go ahead, don't believe.
But if you don't believe
this, you shouldn't believe
any of the miracles in the Bible either.
Which is a, I don't know
if that's a good argument.
- Any other questions?
- If I can add to,
and again, my background
is experimental biology.
It was absolutely, I would call it,
materialist like in the
bad meaning of this word.
And then my son sent me an
article from a paper from Lancet
and Lancet, it's bonafide medical journal.
And it described the
case of a person who was
hit by a truck or something like this,
brought in the emergency room, intubated.
So he was what they call flatlined, right?
And then after that, he
was rescued obviously,
and he was in his room
and when the nurse came, he
said, oh, this is, she is,
she took my dentures so he could describe
that she took the dentures
and put in a certain drawer, right?
While he was flatlined,
and the paper presented
as one of many cases
and discusses others
and as an experimental biologist,
I had to take it as a
fact, from what you say,
wild fact, not fact,
I think it should be
distinction between facts,
which is something verifiable,
and opinions, right?
Somebody can have an opinion
and somebody is flying, you know?
But a fact is a fact.
So the thing is, and it turns
out there's a department
called Perceptual Studies in
the University of Virginia,
that like follow the
work of William James.
And multiple things are documented,
obviously there was a lot
of fraudsters everywhere,
but in science as we know it and accept,
also very fraudsters.
But this is something that is verifiable
and unexplainable.
It's a modern miracle
you can call it, right?
But it's undeniable
because it's documented,
published in Lancet and everything.
So maybe this is what I,
I'm looking forward to read your book,
maybe I'm just repeating what's-
- Thanks, well, I'm glad
you brought up this parallel
because these impossible
things are on a spectrum,
I like to think.
And near death experiences, which is what,
the subject category under
which this research falls
is part of the spectrum
because there's something
undeniable about it.
But there's a vehement disagreement among
scientists and medical personnel
who study this phenomenon.
And I just spent the past three days
reading some of this back and forth,
and I was stunned to
discover that there is a
journal of near death
experiences, which was run out of
University of Virginia in the center for,
what was the title of the?
(audience member answers question)
Yeah, perceptual studies.
And ironically,
I spent 15 years at the
University of Virginia
and didn't know this center was there.
I had to come here 27
years later, find out,
oh, they were next door.
But yeah, I appreciate what
you're saying very much.
- But I guess the question is,
there are many such things in
neuroscience as well, right?
There are phantom arms, people
feel pain in phantom arms
and so on, and the question is,
I'm not sure miracle is the word,
I think mystery might be a better word
for something like that,
because miracle is loaded.
- You feel something,
before about the near death experiences,
I thought, well, if you're drunk,
I mean, I didn't experience
myself to this extent,
but I only see a small
green animals running around
and people can see many things.
But if you can verify what the person-
- And replicate and replicate.
- Verify, yeah, just say, it
says it was there and it is,
and there's no way he could see.
You have to stop and say,
look, we dunno how we work,
we dunno how the brain
works, something fundamental.
And like this stuff comes out in there.
- There are numerous puzzling
wild facts of this sort that
go into the 20th century.
You might re recall, I refused to call
Maria de Agreda the greatest
bilocator of all time.
Reason for this is that just
at the end of my research,
it was too late for me to
include this in the book,
and it was the wrong century.
I discovered that in the 20th century,
there was a French nun who
bilocated more frequently
and even more outrageously
than Maria De Agreda.
And at the very same time,
rescued French resistance
fighters and downed allied pilots
by dressing them as nuns
and escorting them out of
the hands of the Nazis.
But most of her levitations
were to prisons and concentration camps.
And some of the testimonies
are from individuals
who claim she came, comforted them,
or in some cases helped them escape.
And for some odd, I can't figure this out
because she died in 1951,
and there's a lot of French
language literature on her.
There's nothing in
English, nothing in German,
nothing in Spanish,
nothing in any language other than French.
She's not known outside of France.
You can find her on YouTube, however.
But, that's always a dicey proposition.
But yeah, there are these puzzling things.
I also found a very, somebody
again emailed me this,
something that happened during the 1970s
that I was totally unaware of, which was
an apparition of the Virgin
Mary in the 1970s of all places,
a suburb of Cairo, Zaytoun,
which was viewed by over a million people
over a period of two years every night
and was in all the Egyptian
newspapers, of course,
but never made it to any
newspaper I read in the 1970s.
And most of the viewers were
Muslims, not Christians.
So these, I love these wild
facts that just throw you
for a loop and leave you
wondering how it is that,
well, one way of put it
with small brackets, how
belief is constructed
or how belief is reported.
Those two things have a lot
to do with people's exposure
to these kinds of phenomena.
- Thank you so much for your
presentation, it was wonderful.
You talked about how people are reporting,
the people who wrote these
stories 500 years ago,
or even our sacred stories
had a whole different vision
and understanding of the
cosmos than we do today.
And yet this is particularly
true of our theologians,
we still go back and interpreted them
based on their
interpretation of the cosmos.
They wrote it from that, and we look at it
and say, well, this is how it was,
even though they had this
whole different vision of it.
I also just wanted to say
your story about Mary,
Mary is one of the most
revered women in Islam,
she's one of the only women
mentioned in the Quran.
So it's not surprising
at all that in Egypt
it would be a lot of Muslim
women that were there.
It's not, people sometimes
are shocked by that,
but it's not a surprise.
But the whole idea of how do we reimagine
our science and our theology
not based on what they wrote 2000 years,
and, not to throw out the
baby with the bath water
to use an old Irish expression,
to take that wonderful work,
but understand it from how we
understand the cosmos today?
- Right, and no, I agree
with you that that is a,
that's a real challenge.
However, the testimony
is not all from clerics
who are writing hagiographies,
the canonization inquests are,
they're almost like legal proceedings.
And they ask for testimony
from all different sorts of people.
- [Moderator] They're rooted in faith.
- I'm sorry?
- [Priyamvada] All of these,
interlocutors in that are rooted in faith.
- Right, and this scholar at
Rice University, I mentioned
Jeffrey Krippal, he has argued that
belief as a social phenomenon,
as a social fact has a lot to do
with the occurrence of
these impossible events
and impossible phenomena.
That there's a correlation
between the belief
and the events.
Although there's no easy way
to explain it scientifically
unless one has discovered proof of,
interpenetrating dimensions,
which has yet to yet to be accomplished.
But I think my Welsh scientist
was very, very excited by
the suspension of time space,
something I cannot understand.
And I don't know what, how widely believed
he will be in his own
scientific community.
- We close with, oh, one final question.
- Some of the narrative
details of the depictions,
for instance, the crowd
is pretty reverential.
- Oh yeah.
- [Audience member]
Well, and I'm thinking if
someone levitated in front of me,
if I didn't know them,
I might be scared that I
was gonna levitate too,
or that they were gonna fall on me.
If it was my friend
Nancy, I would be pulling,
holding onto her so that
she didn't float away.
But there seems like a
standard in these photos,
the pictures, that this is
how you treat a levitation.
- That's the depiction,
the actual accounts are very different.
People are frightened half to death often,
in the description of the accounts,
they're frightened half to death,
and terror is one of the words used.
Or the equivalent of
the English word terror.
The funny thing is that, I
don't know if you know of the
illusionist David Blaine.
David Blaine, there was a
documentary on David Blaine
years ago, like at least two decades ago,
where he was performing tricks
on the street in Manhattan.
And one of his tricks was levitation,
which has all to do with
how you place your feet.
And the camera in this documentary
was always aimed at his feet,
very rarely at his whole body.
But you could see that
from certain perspective,
it looked like his feet
were off the ground.
But what I liked is that the camera
also turned to the audience,
and at least the clips they
chose for the documentary,
everyone is backing away from him.
The body language is
constant in all those clips,
everybody's going and then
they, there's an image
of a young woman saying,
oh, he must be very holy.
So yeah, if I saw somebody levitating,
I think I would maybe run out of the room.
Not just back away, but,
scary stuff sometimes.
I did fail to mention
that every time Joseph
of Cupertino went up,
he let out some sound, loud sound.
And the Italian words are shout,
strilo, or screech and urlo,
some kind of basso profundo
detonation of sorts, which one time,
according to several testimonies,
made the walls of the monastery shake
and the monks run out
of their cells yelling,
earthquake, earthquake, that's scary too.
Did it happen?
Well, nobody will be able to prove it,
we don't have film.
but I just received an email
yesterday from some TV program
that claims they have
film of people levitating
and they want me to comment and I said,
I don't know of any films
of people levitating,
sure sign me up, I wanna see these.
- Carlos, this wonderful
presentation reminded me
of the miracle of Lanciano and
other eucharistic miracles.
So the heart of every Catholic mass
is the consecration as you mentioned.
So it's, suppose you could term it a
quotidian kind of miracle, right?
It's oft repeated every
mass, every day, every hour,
everywhere in the world.
There are like the miracle of Lanciano,
explicitly rendered
hosts eucharists, right?
That bleed and are still preserved thusly.
You mentioned Luther
and how he believed in the true presence,
but subsequent Protestants
and obviously Protestantism
in general strayed from that.
Could you walk us through a bit
how we went from Luther
believing in the presence
to his contemporaries, let's
say, and soon thereafter?
- Yeah, sure, it's at the
critical turning point
in the history of the
Protestant Reformation
is that Luther continued to
believe in the real presence,
but he didn't like the
term transubstantiation
or the concept of transubstantiation
'cause it required you
to be an Aristotelian
and understand what was meant
by substance and accident.
And also because there's no description
of what happens in Jesus's word.
So he was being very biblical about it.
But he insisted if Jesus says,
take this and eat, this is my body, right?
That was the bottom line for him.
So in 1529, he and all
the other major reformers
of that period meet in one
room at Marburg in Germany.
They had been brought
together by Philip of Hesse,
the most powerful Lutheran
prince of the time,
so that they can form a military alliance
among all the different
branches of Protestantism,
including those Swiss who fight so well.
No agree, they agree on 13 points,
they cannot agree on 14, the Eucharist.
And Luther actually writes on
the table according, we have
notes that were taken by
four different people,
so we have four different transcripts.
They all say, Luther wrote
on the table with chalk
Hoc est corpus meum in
Latin, this is my body.
And then he put a little cloth over it.
And every time, the Swiss, especially
who didn't believe in the
real presence brought up.
But is, could be a metaphor.
Jesus also said, I am the
vine, you are the branches.
He's being metaphorical.
Luther would say, no,
no, it's not a metaphor.
No, no, no, and then he'd
lift up the little cloth
and point to the word
est, est, est means est.
It kind of reminded me of you know,
the Bill Clinton affair years ago,
what is something?
The semantics got involved,
but Luther finally got just,
they started insulting
each other at Marburg
and Luther at one point says,
and you'll have to pardon my German,
look, Christ not only
said this is my body,
he says, take this and eat.
He says, if God had
commanded me to eat scheiss,
I would have to.
So it's the word of God,
God can do anything.
So the Swiss come back at him
and say, look, Jesus has a human body.
His resurrected body was fully human
and it went up to heaven.
A human body cannot be
in two places at once.
Luther responds, you're
being too mathematical.
God is all powerful, God can
be everywhere if he wants to.
And the discussion goes
on and on and on and on.
They can't agree and no military alliance.
So that's how it diverged.
And in the Anglican Church,
the definition of the Eucharist
is unclear enough to suggest
both symbol and presence,
at least the 1549 book of common prayer.
So there are these differences.
- Thank you so much once again.
So let's all thank Carlos for-
- Thank you, thank you all, thank you.
(applause)
(slow music)